all right hey what what's up I'm here
you're kicking this out podcast I showed
up yeah what I don't see a banjo or a
guitar in your hands were you going to
play us I was gonna I was gonna you know
give people like a hip-hop beat or
something with my with it's a good thing
I started this podcast good thing you
started it yeah
um yeah it's been a while since I've
been in a podcast
yeah welcome back episode 177 yeah dang
dude and uh today I threw out this idea
to talk about Reddit in this the
craziness it's been kind of going down
over there
um and everybody in the room's kind of
looking at me like okay what are you
talking about and this is my perfect
segue into an introduction to explain
the context here so
um
read it about a month ago announced it
was going to increase the price for API
access so basically if an app that lets
you look at Reddit want to Ping Reddit
servers and say hey can you can I have
this page can you can I download the
information for like this comment or
whatever
there's a cost associated with that in
Reddit took that cost and in the span of
30 days uh 20x did they turned it up oh
my God two thousand percent
um
to which every third-party app developer
went whoa I can't 20x my Revenue in 30
days guys and they're like oh well we'll
definitely work with you guys to figure
something out like okay I sent you an
email
all right and uh that's it so this we
told you actually 20x that's it the end
done in like and so what's actually
happening now is all these third-party
apps are shutting down because they
can't just generate you know millions of
dollars of Revenue in the span of 30
days and they're you know they're like
hey we could try to spin this up you
know we could like we do have
subscribers you know there's there's a
lot of these apps are really big apps
what's an example of one of those like
Apollo would be a third-party Reddit app
okay that yeah
let's try to give a specific like
doesn't have to be an example but a
specific way that this would affect a
business so people yeah so I mean
totally understand any any user using
Apollo the developer of Apollo are all
just shut out now and it's done they're
closing down the app and I think they
actually closed it down if I'm not
mistaken already
um what is Apollo for people who don't
know it's an app that lets you browse
Reddit it lets you look at Reddit you
can use the official Reddit app which a
lot of people say is garbage and it's
actually lacking a lot of tools that
these other apps have so people have
been using other programs which they
have been doing for years in fact that's
what I was doing for a while before I
deleted all Reddit apps because they
raised the cost Apollo which is an app
specifically for a better Reddit
browsing experience can no longer ping
Reddit servers at the same cost that
they were able to do before because
everything on the internet costs money
it's called it's bandwidth right
obviously video costs the most but you
know just even simple data costs money
yeah so uh but the move here was like
very much not in good faith whatsoever
because there's no attempt whatsoever to
work with this yeah any of these app
developers because it wasn't a oh we're
going to increase like they actually
said in January they weren't going to
increase costs and they did increase
cost but they did a 30-day window which
they know is impossible to meet no you
can't 20x your Revenue in 30 days like
it's just impossible so it's it's very
clearly a move to destroy and shut down
all these third-party apps but not just
that that's the narrative that everybody
kind of hears right so there's another
aspect here which is reddit is the one
of the last points on the internet where
things are written by human beings and
granted there's still a lot of bots on
Reddit but for the most part if you're
looking for something that a human being
has written and not some garbage search
result on Google you type Reddit in into
your Google search term yeah I do that
for sure I do that all the time it's the
only way I can find something that's
actually useful and written by a person
and something that's not like filler
garbage that plays the algorithm that
Google needs to show up on their front
page because Google no longer serves
the consumer you know you don't get the
results you need on Google anymore it
serves you sites that have the most
Google ads on them because it's just a
modern like television station they're
just like how many you know brought them
through boys
so if you have a situation here where
the people running Reddit are looking at
the fact they're one of the most popular
websites on the internet
they are basically they're they're
Google's only source of real results and
they're also where all the data is
getting pulled to be trained for things
like chat GPT
and they're like wait a minute how are
we this big and not billionaires yet and
so these they're like well let's create
an IPO let's start going public and
let's start making some money first
things first all this content on Reddit
is ours
um
AKA API access no more third-party apps
no more and hey all you users don't
forget everything you've given to us is
ours so all you AI companies that want
to train off things that people have
written pay us and suddenly this calls
into light this question of the content
on Reddit it is not reddit's it's on
their server the content was created by
thousands if not millions of people
right the content belongs to all of the
people that created it like the stuff
I've written on Reddit doesn't belong to
Reddit right it's those are words I put
up there and there's always been this
sense of community on Reddit of like
it's it's it's a forum it's a user base
the moderators are working for free the
people that kept that site as much as
they can free from spam and garbage and
made it a usable Community it was all
community-led and Community Driven so
it's been community community community
and suddenly the people on top of the
company are like well I would rather
make a lot of money and and and we've
seen this kind of before but it's it's
so blatant now it's tough for them
because they they've fostered a
community of like very aware people and
so when they pull the switch of like
okay what actually all this content you
guys have written for years we are going
to shut all the gates so we can monetize
it you know the the community's like
well screw you guys like hey we didn't
we're not getting any cut of that b it
isn't yours to begin with and like all
these other you know aspects around that
and when I see this happening I see
Reddit looking at the likes of like Tick
Tock and Instagram and Facebook and
going ah these these billion dollar
companies somehow managed to convince
people to make all their content for
them for free you know and this is this
is one thing like that's distinctive
about YouTube is YouTube didn't do that
from like the get-go YouTube's basically
had a 50 50 split but when you look at
like the stuff going up on Tick Tock the
stuff going on Instagram you're not
making any money on that like yeah these
companies have have effectively made
billions of dollars by getting everybody
to make the thing that people watch on
these platforms for free like we we
scoff at like the notion of like paying
somebody an exposure like hey will you
just like could you like you know shoot
my my short film and I'll I'll give you
a credit we're like no screw that like
that such that's so manipulative and
like extortionistic you know but for
tick tock to be like hey I'll give you
I'll give you likes and eyeballs if you
make content for me no I'm not gonna
give you any money no no We're not gonna
pay you even though you're the work
you've done as a girl on the value of
our company by billions of dollars
about Tick Tock monetization so for
those of you who don't know
um Tick Tock has they have Tick Tock
pulse and then they also recently have
Tick Tock pulse Premiere but it's
basically the same thing and what it is
is
is uh
you put your video out if you have more
than a hundred thousand followers
if that video is in the top four percent
of a certain number of categories I
think it's 12 that Tick Tock defines as
like okay these are good to put ads on
if your video is in the top four percent
of that you get a 50 50 monetization but
only well it's within the top four
percent of that category oh my which is
usually for
you know 24 hours or less
and so the monetization is just
abhorrent comparative to like YouTube
long form and then there's all these
other role like in YouTube did you know
their their roll out of monetization of
YouTube shorts and it's not much better
I mean it's it's a instead of it being
55 to the Creator and 45 to YouTube It's
45 to the Creator and 55 to YouTube and
again it's just like uh
it's pennies compared to you know what
what are otherwise dollars it's worth
pointing out the YouTube shorts make
like maybe 100 bucks for 10 million
views you know maybe more yeah I mean
you might if it's longer you might make
600 bucks the point is for 10 million
views okay where is whereas a standard
monetization of that type on a long form
video say it's you know predominantly us
audience and yada yada you know the the
CPM on that is going to be like
somewhere between 10 and 16 dollars
uh dollars per dollars per thousand
views so you're gonna make sixteen
thousand
versus 600 yeah
everyone's an actual like hey you built
the content for our platform people
watch it here's Revenue like one's yeah
actual Revenue
which like two YouTube's credit I look
at all of these modern media companies
YouTube is the only one that from the
get-go is like all right content
creators get a cut
you know and not like I mean it's not
great but it's it's fine you know it's
like we've been able to make a business
at it for 12 years so I've never got the
sense that it was like unfair because
YouTube's been also pioneering the whole
like how do we build an ad environment
in an ad ecosystem
in in the world of online like they
started it they forged that like and
there's they've learned like there's
real life like networking that needs to
happen you can't just algorithmically do
ads you need to have sales reps they
need to talk to companies like it's a
person-to-person business at the end of
the day and so there's all this
infrastructure behind it like you know
yeah I've never gotten the feeling that
YouTube at least for the normal content
has ripped people off like
now when it comes to shorts are they
ripping us off or is there actually just
no money in shorts I don't know well
they say they say it's both and but
that's you know they so they started
with the pilot program and they said
okay we're gonna have a fund and Tick
Tock did the same thing they started
with a fund and and that was to
encourage people to like figure out okay
what is monetizable for Brands and then
let's try to get brands in and get brand
money in but
you know I I see it going down the same
road as Facebook which is just like
somehow
somehow they haven't been able to come
up with a system that actually benefits
people for making genuinely good shows
and content on their platform
yeah Facebook hasn't I mean there's
people who what's that yeah Facebook
yeah I mean YouTube has Facebook hasn't
YouTube has yeah but that's this for the
whole time they've been like ah guys we
just can't can't quite swing it you know
and it's like you you guys have like
what like 20 30 of like the you know
like the developed world's ad money
online and you can't come up with a
system for like just the metaverse dude
I build the metaverse it seem like the
Facebook like Facebook content lately
it's no
there's so many
like
you think they're going to be a one
minute Tick Tock but then you look at
the run time and it's 20 minutes oh no
but it's paced like a tick tock and
they'll just be like there I saw one
recently where it was like a really
staged like black belt versus corrupt
cop Showdown like body cam footage
and it was just like them standing there
and arguing in karate stances for 20
minutes it's like a Dragon Ball Z
episode
yeah how is that what what sells man
yeah so like to Circle this all back to
Reddit what we're seeing here is Reddit
seen Tick Tock pull this off and seen
Facebook pull this off
and it's like I want that I need that
and
and they're trying to make it happen but
they've built this site off this culture
for over a decade of not being that and
it's kind of imploding and it's a little
sad to see and I mean I get was it
Sheldon Freud showden how do you
pronounce it schadenfreude I don't know
how to pronounce it but uh I get a
little bit of that from watching it
happen um but
you know I shouldn't the against the
higher-ups at Reddit yeah just I'm just
watching like because they're I think
there are a lot of problems with Reddit
I feel like it really fostered just like
it happened on Facebook and Twitter it
also really fostered a lot of
communities of like ignorance and MOB
like violent not yeah mob violence mob
mentality mob anger whereas it wasn't
about taking a moment to like talk
things out it was about jumping on the
thing that gets the biggest outrage
reaction first which gets the most
upvotes and then you build a mob a
literal mob and you know it's an online
mob it's a cyber mob but still it's a
mob and I you know it was happening way
too much I just I didn't really see any
attempts from the people that run Reddit
to like really try to curb that part of
the culture so you know
you sing that part get caught up and I'm
like yeah okay whatever you know it's
that's fine it's nice seeing that part
get taken down a little bit but like
yeah more so it brings into this like
this perspective that I've seen more and
more which I wish these companies
didn't exist just for the sake of making
money
but instead the culture was doing the
best you can at what the company is
supposed to do like like Nintendo your
their job is to make video games and
don't get me wrong you need to make
money as a company and you need to make
money if you want to do crazy things
like make the Nintendo switch and tears
of the Kingdom right those things cost
money but like once you've created that
ecosystem and you're successful as a
company and you have the money you need
to do these projects and you have the
best of the talent working at your
company at that point the culture needs
to change from being how much more money
can we make too how can we be the best
at this like Nintendo when they make
stuff it's how can we make the best dang
video games the world's ever seen be
like it's not how can we monetize DLC in
like this free to play shooter to make
the most money you know like tears of
the Kingdom has zero of that right it's
just it's literally you start playing it
and it's just a work of art
and
Reddit had like Reddit has this thing
where it's like it was the internet's
community and it's too bad the goals
aren't to continue being the best
internet Community out there see what
the goals are now how can we take all
this user content that for years was
created on our platform or put on our
platform for our platform how can we
take all of that and now make it mine so
I can charge everybody access to it even
though I didn't create it even though
I'm not going to cut any of these
billions with the people that made it
even though the moderators did all that
work for free even though all the users
put it up there in good faith open
discussion how can I now take all that
and make it mine and it's it's scummy
and I hate it this is what happens when
you IPO yeah I mean this is there's
there's good and valuable contributions
that many public companies have made
incredible contributions to humanity but
the goal becomes how much money can you
make like the shareholders really yes
that's what it becomes about and it's
it's just that's that's just the nature
of the Beast
um and
we've seen this happen with you know
people that we know who have done IPOs
like you know they for example I won't I
won't name who it is but we had some
people that we knew that did an IPO and
the entire culture of their organization
changed
they brought in people from you know X Y
and Z parts of the chain such and such
World from other public companies to do
you know to come in and be their manager
this manager that VP of this VP of that
and the whole thing became about like
well we just we need to get rid of this
and you need to do more of this you need
to do less of that all for the sake of
just like making the company more
valuable
as that being the goal yeah they're
going to do the thing they did at all
the other companies that worked at right
like when YouTube Red hired a bunch of
like TV Executives it's like wow it
feels like I'm watching old TV
I mean I know they know how to develop
shows cool it's like but you're gonna
get the whole reason people aren't on TV
like or sorry you get the whole like
you're gonna forget the whole reason
people are on YouTube it's not to watch
TV they don't put TV on YouTube I
already didn't want to watch it that's
why I'm on YouTube you know
yeah yeah it's too bad to see that I was
shocked to hear that they were gonna IPO
yeah
I mean if parties like my perspective on
it's always been like you can't make
that money privately
with your business like if your business
just can't make that Revenue
how is going public going to help
outside of just like getting a bunch of
debt and cashing out which I guess you
know for the people in charge that's
great to cash out that's what they do
yeah that's that's part of the deal and
then you leave it in the hands of these
corporatists to
figure out what to do with it after that
I mean I look at valve and valve has
never gone public you know and they're
like the stewards of steam right that is
their job and it's their job is not to
make the most money possible they need
money to do their job and they're making
money and I'm sure they like the amount
of money they're making because they're
making a lot but at the end of the day
steam It's All About Steam and that's
their focus and they're always working
on it and it's always there it's like
and it is like the shining example of
like PC gaming and like the marketplace
in the storefront well in every game
they put out is like saying it's like
tears of the Kingdom where it's just
like there's nothing in here that is
meant to just milk you actually except
for Team Fortress 2. oh okay
but yeah and DOTA no they actually they
invented that whole monetization scheme
but still like they're like there still
is clearly a goal to make the best
product with valve also at least when it
comes to steam specifically
but you know all their games like portal
Counter-Strike you know they're
incredible games yeah exactly live you
know the index
yeah it's a real weird thing that we're
in right now where there's
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
being generated on ad Revenue being
spent online
with hyper-specific focus on Roi and way
better conversion than you ever got with
print media or traditional TV yeah so
not only does it work better
but there's more money being spent on it
now than there ever was in the
traditional mediums and somehow because
the distribution is accessible to
everybody
it's just
they're getting content for free
basically which is crazy um it's like
the entire model it's weird that our
culture doesn't see that it's weird that
people aren't like oh like slave labor
exploited slave labor I mean it's not
you're not forced to do it you're forced
to do it it's like it's like it's like
everybody's an intern well I think right
that's the interesting thing with Tick
Tock is that the the kind of bar for the
content is so
kind of low in terms of you know there's
good stuff on there good informational
stuff but the production quality is not
good at all it's just somebody filming
on their phone like each individual
person it's you look at it and go well
you know that's it's pretty low quality
but it's like
millions of videos up being uploaded
every day probably and the it's the sum
total of everybody's contribution but
then the company just takes all of it
which is just there's like three million
uploads to YouTube every hour or
something like that yeah something crazy
and that's just that's just YouTube I'm
sure there's more on Tick Tock because
it's shorter form
but yeah it's uh
it's wild
um I'm not sure where it goes
um but it is it is a little bit weird
and you know when you look at like
uh over those movies with Jennifer
Lawrence and she's in like the The
Hunger Games oh yeah it feels a little
bit like that doesn't corporate Hunger
Games whereas we have a website that has
all these viewers and we will give them
to you if you can kill all these other
channels around you yeah and like the
people who really make it on these
platforms you know they come out dressed
just like in The Hunger Games movies you
know it's like where did you get these
wacky clothes I can't even pronounce
your rapper name like I don't even know
what it is
and it's yeah
um it's just a weird phenomena
there is one point I think in the
history of the development of like you
know monetizing videos and all that that
was really pivotal and I'm gonna give
YouTube credit again here because it's
compliments to YouTube so there's a
phase where everybody started doing
brand Integrations where we're all like
Hey Okay ad revenue is cool I mean in
the early days you actually didn't get
ads for like until like 48 hours after
your video went up so like most reviews
kind of already happened
page to like sit there for a while two
you can also and also YouTube would
glitch out so if you're lucky enough to
be on the front page you might be up
there for a week sometimes and that's a
lot of views
[Laughter]
um but since ad revenue is all over the
place
um people were like well we do have an
audience and there's plenty of other you
know forms of media out there to take
inspiration from like you know say talk
radio let's just take sponsors and we'll
just have our own sponsors in our media
YouTube can still run ads but yeah we'll
have AKA brand Integrations
um and this is the early days of that
right that wasn't really a thing like
there was no FTC like disclaimer that
you had to do you didn't have to say
videos are sponsored but YouTube rather
than like for a brief moment they're
like oh should we allow it or should we
take a cut and like I think there's a
conversation like a there's no way
you're gonna be able to control it if
you try to take a cut like people are
just not going to pay you and B if you
disallow it you're gonna kill your
platform yeah and YouTube to their
credits like okay we're just gonna back
off we're just gonna make sure that
there's the FTC disclaimer and we'll
make sure people know about that but if
people want to monetize their own
content into their own private like
contracts
go for it even though it's on our
platform even though we are running ads
against it go for it and to this day
it's been very hands-off and like and we
can keep 100 of our own brand
Integrations that we we sell
there's no conflicts with YouTube ads
there's like we don't have to like fuss
with that at all and I can't believe
it's a system where we have that much
freedom I can't believe that they were
that like that chill about it be like no
it's yours which it is ours you know at
the end of the day like it's our you
know context
inventory Nico how much host red
inventory do you have to sell
do other platforms are there any that
disallow that or
because it's like a tick tock is way too
short for somebody to be like let me
tell you about expressvp are you sure
about that so they did set the precedent
and most of the way that people who have
blown up on Instagram or uh on Tick Tock
are making a living is through brand
Integrations yeah for sure that's almost
the entirety of how they make money
um and so yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah um that's if you're making a
living on Tick Tock it's I mean if
there's somebody out there
who is making it on Tick Tock Revenue
please comment I would love to know but
he's the most famous person in the world
yeah I was reading um there was some
Creator who has like they did an
assessment on like he has you know on
like they did an assessment on like two
billion views that he had and he was
like oh yeah that's just like um you
know that's just like extra Revenue most
of what I make is through brand
Integrations like
yeah wild there's kind of a parallel
here with uh one of the arguments from
The Writer's Guild
uh is about specifically about streamers
which I really take to heart is that
once again these like
massive corporations they're all making
their own streaming service and the only
way that they catch steam is when they
have a good show on there with good
writing you know uh just think about
like Netflix with house cards or even
HBO Max with like some of those shows
succession and stuff like that
and it's kind of the same thing where
it's like you know
I mean even though those at least those
writers are being paid something whereas
like these creators on other platforms
don't get paid anything it's still this
like they're creating the thing that
gives the company any value
and um it's just this totally imbalanced
share of the profits
yeah I mean Netflix has 220 some million
paying subscribers globally yeah that's
insane
when the minimum that you can pay is
like 7.99 with ads
220 million people are paying you eight
dollars a month and you're charging ads
holy [__]
speaking of uh speaking of Netflix and
brand Integrations and YouTube
I don't know if there's a tinfoil hat
conspiracy or if it's like you know if
I'm on to something but the recent like
have you all been experiencing the the
thing with Netflix where like the
household sharing where you have the
password thing I
I feel like that is a direct response to
all of the VPN ads that are telling
people like hey guess what get XYZ VPN
and you can pretend you're logging into
Netflix from Sweden
yeah I feel like right that is why
Netflix is cracking down on that yeah
yeah I think that's part of it for sure
um there was a time there was a time
when Netflix Twitter sent out a tweet
that said love is sharing your password
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yeah I think it's that I think it's
also just you know they're trying to
um they're trying to make more money and
they at first it wasn't a problem
because when they ipo'd they had so much
growth potential and they just grew and
grew and grew for like a decade that
company just grew based on subscriber
base and then they had that snafu last
fall where they lost you know half of
their Market valuation in like two weeks
and then all of a sudden they said ah
God no more password sharing uh let's
let's shut this down
yeah it's just great the streaming thing
is so weird it's this insane model where
it's like we're just gonna grow forever
which I guess is like every like public
company but like at some point you run
out of the number of people who can
subscribe to your streamer like you just
like why can't you be like some like
Japanese ink maker where he's like I
just exist to make the best calligraphy
Inc and that's all I do like why can't
Netflix once you have two 120 million
subscribers okay can they just be like
we exist to make the best shows and
that's the only reason we're here yeah
why is it still about and no password
sharing
you know it's like guys you have 220
million subscribers everything on their
platform Netflix originals
like in infinite growth is gonna like
there is not infinite resources whether
it's viewers whether it's yeah you got
you got to be doing it because you love
it
yeah your phone doesn't like you staying
in Discord it really does it
Griffin's phone is mattered
yeah so YouTube launched their shorts
thing a while back yeah we just kind of
like their answer to tick tock and kind
of like Instagram and I don't know how
it's doing I don't really like check up
on that stuff but you know it's become
quite invasive like when you open the
YouTube app and it just goes straight it
doesn't do that to me because I'm so
anti-shorts it doesn't know so it knows
it knows because I actually do
let me see what happens when I open it
right now I watch a lot of like cooking
content and that is the best shorts
content on any platform because it's
just somebody making a thing and you can
just watch that I can watch that for
like you know a long time so I get lost
in that so maybe I'm a shorts okay so
the first thing it did was give me an ad
for YouTube Prime Time official TV shows
now on YouTube
and then yep the first thing it gives me
is shorts and I don't even watch shorts
on my phone
let's see I'm gonna quit YouTube it
gives me an ad and then it gives me
shorts no it gives me home it gives me
the home screen which is just videos and
some yeah so and when you scroll through
your feed how often is it showing you
bars of shorts
because I even in my subscriber feed I'm
scrolling through and every other sort
of row is shorts
and it's like it's all over for me
so you don't get it as you're kind of
scrolling through no it's it's just
videos for me it's interesting because
well I I dislike this idea of companies
trying to distract you or it's like if I
open Instagram to look at the post my
friends make and if I scroll a little
too far and there's like a really
curiosity inducing like real that's like
right under there it's it's so blatantly
like they're trying to like hey hey look
hey hey it's like yo shut up stop like
I'm not here for you to like hit me with
some shocking video or something like I
just wanted to see what my friend's post
was and I scrolled through the feed once
I got to the end I wanted it to stop and
it really happened feed scroll now is
there's things you're not well on
Instagram no files you're not following
once again I also turned off any
suggestions you can only turn them off
for a month at a time but I did it every
month that it popped up I've never
really turn it off for a month at a time
yeah in fact I may maybe I did it enough
that just gave up on me
um because I haven't had that suggestion
for a while my feed like my feed is only
people I follow I I the moment it is not
that I quit Instagram like I do not want
to follow random people online I only
want to follow people I want to follow
and thank the YouTube subscriptions also
does that
um but yeah so like Instagram you know
they try to distract you YouTube's like
well everybody loves shorts I guess and
all these companies are making billions
of dollars we should probably try it
um so they have shorts and you know one
of the things was like Hey guys if you
guys make shorts It's really helpful for
reaching wider audiences on YouTube and
we're like oh let's give it a shot we
made some shorts they went viral they
hit wider audiences we're like wow they
were right let's try it again let's do
some more of this
and then we realized that the people
watching shorts on YouTube are not the
people that go and watch Long YouTube
videos at the same time it's different
audiences and we also realized that
we're not we're not creators or
influences where our faces our currency
where our personalities our currency
we're like we're not Will Smith where
it's like videos of us is what people
watch like we're creators and people
want to see what we make right they want
to see the renders we make or the films
we make or whatever the experiments that
we do and like you know cool like we're
not we're not annoying personalities you
know we don't ruin the videos of her in
them but like people aren't necessarily
coming to the videos to watch like me
crack some jokes for example and so
having a short with us in it also
doesn't boost our value at all because
our faces aren't our currency and so now
we're caught in the spot where it's like
well maybe shorts aren't worth our time
even if there are views there because
there's no ad Revenue
the audience that watches them is not
the same audience that's going to go and
watch like a 15 minute long VFX Artistry
Act
and they don't actually build value
because it's our work that's our value
and a short kind of cheapens your work
and it's not our face that's the value
and that's kind of the main thing that
you put in it short and so yeah I don't
know shorts yeah I'm curious about it
I'm curious I was digging into some of
the analytics today to really get to the
bottom of the question of whether or not
people who come to our channel from a
short actually end up watching the long
form videos which is what they're known
as now we we used to call them shorts
because it was comparison to movies and
television but now it's considered long
form
um and I haven't gotten to the an
empirical bottom yet to understand
exactly that
but that's kind of what we need to we
need to crack is is whether or not
that's actually
oh
[Music]
did your power go out they're on this
you're still here your internet's still
up oh my internet's still up okay yeah
how is that possible it's because I have
my well my
well hold on actually my Russian my
breaker I might just have to 15 seconds
until they get to your location okay but
anyways let me let me flip this breaker
that's the thought I'll leave you with
I'll be right back
like are you getting uh getting attacked
by like a SWAT team or something like
that yeah dude I think the Russians are
in this is Red Red Dawn for Jake if it
10 minute video is considered long form
how long until like a short is just like
a dopamine release like flashing light
pattern yeah yeah it's like the
scientists learned that if you flash red
and blue back and forth to the green
every five seconds it induces the same
dopamine hit as a tick tock dance video
[Music]
yeah that's weird man
it's weird do you either you guys spend
any time on Reddit what's your social
media of choice I would say I used to
spend more time on Reddit I would say
Instagram is like the number one well
besides YouTube I spend you know I would
say I watch YouTube as much as I watch
any streamer or anything like that but
yeah outside of that Instagram and then
Instagram is really my engagement with
like the actual content that's being
made on there is like
if there's cool artists making stuff
I'll follow them I'll surf the explore
page but really it's I like I'll I'll
sort of like find myself on the explore
page I don't remember how I got there so
I'm just like oh what am I doing this is
just random garbage and then I like turn
off the app but yeah YouTube is like the
main way
consume content I'm back I'm I'm with
you on that hi Jake watch a ton of
YouTube and I am active on Reddit but I
am active in exactly one Community uh I
am I only use Reddit to go on the the
fingerboarding I was gonna say Tech Deck
yeah so that I can just go and be
encouraging to like kids who are just
starting out it's like it's like the one
nice thing I do a day it's gonna be like
good form man keep it up yeah my Reddit
experience got a lot better when I
literally cut out every single default
sub and like I basically follow the
corridor subreddit the stable diffusion
subreddit and then like
I don't know like two or three other
like wacky tiny subreddits
yeah mine was like back in the day was
the DC Comics subreddit oh hell yeah
Dean yeah I knew you were on that but
then uh it became very toxic once the
Zack Snyder movies started coming out
because he has like this like super
rabid fan base okay
um
but yeah yeah I I on my phone I really
only check Instagram on my phone I don't
really watch YouTube on my phone but I
do watch YouTube almost every night
before I go to bed on my TV
and I I like it because usually it's
like uh it's like a wind down thing I
don't I don't really like very many
narrative shows
I I don't know I just some of them I get
into but if but most of them by and
large I don't really watch them so you
know that leaves you with movies or
YouTube
and it's like yeah I watch movies you
know whatever just like the next person
but a lot of times it's like oh two
hours I don't have two hours to sit like
I gotta go to bed man you know I have
like an hour maybe and so I'll just I
just follow a lot of different uh
shows on YouTube there's a really great
one that I watch a lot called Medieval
Madness which is uh it's it's like
historical breakdowns of certain aspects
of life in the Middle Ages and it's
really good oh that's cool that's
awesome
yeah I feel like it's a it's like an
energy thing with the narrative shows
versus YouTube like my girlfriend I will
eat dinner and we'll like sit down for
something to watch with dinner and we're
like how are we feeling tonight do we
have the energy to like engage in a
narrative thing or because you want to
bring yourself to it yeah but like
YouTube is sort of
get like give me like do the work for me
like sometimes with a narrative show it
feels like you're you're like all right
let's let's actually use our attention
span to like engage in this narrative
but YouTube just comes at you and it's
like here's information here's dopamine
you know yeah
even though it's like I will you know
even if I I sit down and I'm like oh I
don't have two hours to watch a movie
I'll sit down and watch like three hours
of like 15 minutes like like top 10
worst train derailment accidents it's
like eating a freaking burger like
for some reason that feel like is it
just like the the illusion of like
control because it's like yeah I'm not
gonna stop you know you're gonna get
something good it's like going to
McDonald's may not you know you're gonna
get something decent that's at the
Quality you expect no surprises and it's
reliable yeah it's like all reliable a
lot of good shows on YouTube there's a
lot of good trained derailments like
there's a lot of content there and I
don't mean like narrative shows
necessarily but I mean channels who have
established shows just like our channels
where there's a there's a ton of those
and they have really you know the people
know what they're doing they've got good
insights they know how to do the thing
to keep it regular you check it every
couple days there's always something new
it's there's a lot of those I feel like
it feels
at least for myself it fills the whole
of like maybe like reality TV because
I've never consumed that but like it
kind of is that same
I don't know thing but I feel like it's
on YouTube oftentimes it's more like
nutritious because you're getting like
information that you can practically use
or the mid the Medieval Madness Journey
led me also to uh like naval ships
medieval not medieval but Renaissance
period naval ships and then and then
that that led me into like wars in the
Caribbean and then that led me into like
Caribbean and Florida documentaries it's
a really weird path that I've been on
dude it's so fun to go down those rabbit
holes because like I've I've been on a
trajectory this year of like
uh like cave diving accidents to like
last night I watched I watched like the
like the full family tree of the the Old
and New Testament okay wow wow yeah it's
like stuff you would never ever be like
oh yeah I'm I'm gonna look up this
subject I'm very interested in this but
you just see like yeah they should do a
Bible
on that funny enough Griffin
dude
[Laughter]
part of the ocean
laughs
um what are some of you guys favorite
YouTube shows
but Johnny Harris is a big one he's been
really popping off recently he makes
really good stuff
um
who else because oftentimes oh this guy
called internet Shaquille I don't know
if you guys ever heard of him he's
awesome it's like sort of a cooking
channel but he makes like super tight
like 10 to 12 minute videos where it's
like here's this super like uber
specific like cooking technique that you
can Implement like practically in your
life that's not it's not like you gotta
buy this sous vide or something it's
like something that you can really
practically do
um
who else oh there's so many I don't know
Griff do you have any yeah I've been top
10 train derailments my like my two
really big Channel or they're not really
big but like the channels where I like
don't miss an upload are um that chapter
and um Coffee House crime they're two
just like really really good True Crime
documentarians and uh yeah just like
really high quality well-written shows
just on YouTube
that's pretty rad nice yeah but you Jake
uh well like I said there's um Medieval
Madness I've been checking that out and
then um there's a good like uh you know
modern issues uh kind of a interview
style show called California Insider
that's pretty good and then
um there's this farming channel that I'm
always watching called just a few Acres
Farm which is uh this guy that has a
small farm in New York state and it's
it's it's fascinating
um how he makes a living doing what he
does is it more like
Slice of Life almost like primitive Tech
things where he's doing stuff on his
farm or he's just talking about
it's more like it's speaking he's
talking about stuff well he's doing
Slice of Life stuff it's really he he
he's this old former architect who was
an architect for like super long but for
the previous he grew up on a farm in his
previous like seven generations of his
family were farmers in New York so he
understood the trade but he went off and
did architecture for a long time and
then now he makes a living on a small
45-acre farm which is small to make a
living off of when you're doing cattle
farming or beef farming and he sells it
at the local farmers market and to like
people in his community and he makes
YouTube videos about it and it's it's
really fascinating like everything from
how the current agricultural industry is
and how it's kind of set up against
small farms to uh like how to actually
raise the animals and stuff yeah it's
it's good stuff
he was a public speaker so he before so
he like took that and took a lot of the
same principles that he learned in
public speaking and and just sort of I
don't even know if he knows he does this
but he applies these really basic
techniques that we took years to sort of
vet out and figure out about
storytelling and how to do a YouTube
video and how to present an idea and
then like don't waste severe's time and
don't be boring and then have a
conclusion and like all those things and
I think it's because he was a public
speaker but yeah it's it's pretty funny
he's like a 55 year old guy who you
would totally not suspect to have a a
really pretty good YouTube channel and
how many uh subscribers generally do you
would he have like
he has I don't know he gets like 200 to
250 000 views of video that's pretty
good he releases like three to four
times a week so yeah he's doing he's
doing it right because that's what's so
cool to me about YouTube again is like
this direct connection with
like a niche audience or like people who
you're specifically trying to speak to
like there are channels that my
girlfriend watches that are like the
person only has like 50 000 subs or
something but she really connects with
the content that that person makes you
know right it's just speaking to
something specifically in her life but
um right Nico you didn't go what's your
uh YouTube channels that you're watching
uh video game dunking never disappoints
oh dude he's so good
um the writing some of these down the
battle report
um or no uh the operations room and the
Intel report that's what they are uh the
operations room is uh gives you like
basically a top-down map view of famous
battles like told like to the person
detail so like for example like
different uh easy company fights they
went through France it's like here's the
maps here's the movement it's like step
by step Jake's so excited have you seen
the Band of Brothers uh episodes that
detail the Easy Company movements in
France yeah I mean yeah on the Intel
report no no in the Band of Brothers in
the Band of Brothers series it's yeah
probably a lot of the same battles you
should also watch the operations room
okay yeah it's pretty good those guys
are crazy I can't believe they did what
they did
where like every person went in a battle
in World War II like I I don't even
remember everyone who was at my birthday
party three months ago I guess when
bullets are flying everything gets
really seared in your memory ah drama
[Laughter]
um
I've been learning a lot of piano
recently so uh David Bennett piano and
Jason Zach are like the two like piano
guys I've been following
um really good teachers and like really
good at like laying things out in really
understandable way but also being
YouTubers and being interesting at the
same time
uh other than that I don't know that's
about it there's there's a Ganondorf guy
I've been following ever since we
started playing a smash called MGK
Ganondorf oh it's making me so sick he's
sick and he gets like 400 views of video
so I knew he was going to go up to the
platform so I did an area
hey MGK if you're listening to this uh I
would love a training session
I would love to fight you and see see
what you got yeah I gotta look at a few
more for shout outs there's one called
um stylized station he makes really cool
like they're kind of like Unreal Engine
videos but he does a really good job of
uh he'll do some more like in-depth kind
of tutorial videos but
he makes kind of like us really good
broad top level Joe at the gas station
could understand videos about like
really complex 3D topics like Parallax
mapping and we'll do a whole video about
that and um he's really cool
he's really cool hey did you see it did
you see what Smo the Smosh video that
they yeah that's I mimics he's so happy
yeah bought the channel back so rad so
they they bought their Channel back from
uh Rhett and Link Good Mythical Morning
which the reason why Rhett and Link came
to acquire because originally Smosh was
with um
defy yeah and defy had bought them like
a long time ago and then defy went out
of business and then
Smosh
partnered with uh Rhett and Link to stay
alive but
especially yeah that's such a hard like
imagine you know you've created this
YouTube channel it blows up it propels
you to success you're doing your dreams
somebody comes in and says hey we can
help you develop this into something
even bigger you're like okay you know so
far so good let's do it
and then imagine and they buy it from
you but as part of buying it you know
they give you a lot of stock in the
company and then imagine without warning
poof the company disappears all that
stock that you had that they gave you
for your channel disappears this channel
that's yours
didn't disappear but it's not yours
anymore and like imagine that you've
built this whole thing and you've made
all these like decisions in good faith
and then just gone like that's gotta be
so gut-wrenching yeah and like happens
all the time yeah the fact they kept
making stuff kept you know doing what
they want to do and then the fact that
Rhett and Link like were down to sell it
back to them and like put them back in
charge of the channel like it makes me
really happy and it's like it's really
cool to see that there's people out
there that are like putting things back
the way it's supposed to be Nature's
healing guys
the MCN times Nature's healing oh my God
we're still healing from the mcns that's
what it felt like man like I saw that
thumbnail and clicked on it I saw them
sitting there together I was like
maybe things aren't so bad
yeah I mean like we've known both those
guys for like forever I mean ever since
like YouTube was a thing and it's just
like yeah they're really good people and
it's just really cool to see this happen
I'm sure it was scary as heck uh I'm
sure they got a lot of work to do but
you know it's really great that it's
actually happening yeah but that so just
to tie in a point from earlier in this
conversation the whole IPO and you know
businesses for the sake of making money
thing
this is what happens when you take
Venture Capital Money
you take in a lot of times you know
people take it for all the best
intentions
but if they don't want to go down the
road of just getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and big it's like literally
in
what is that Dr Seuss book
The Lorax
no and he's like yeah and he's like hey
what is your intention with this The
Lorax asks him what is your intention
and his like my intention is to just
keep biggering and bickering and
biggering and biggering and that's and
that's what that's how it starts you
take you know you take priests you take
seed money
and then you know it's pre-profit money
and then you know you have to prove up
how you're going to make profit for the
people who gave you the seed money and
then once you get to that point then
they go all right let's do a Let's do an
a round let's do a series a round and
then oh let's do a series B round
meanwhile the entire company just chip
start chipping away you know your
control of it well you bring in on all
this debt and then in order to pay back
the debt you you have to continue to
grow because that's the only way that
you can pay back the debt at a rate that
is acceptable to the investors and yeah
it's just it's a strange thing and and
unless that's exactly what you want to
do or you're like no I'm going to make a
product and I'm gonna take seed money
and then I'm gonna do this and then I'm
gonna do this and then I'm gonna do this
and then that's yeah literally if you're
like making like an air conditioner or
shoes it's like I want to sell this to
everybody right but it makes sense to
grow it as big as you can right you know
there's yeah there's not a lot of Art in
the air conditioner you know I I think
so I'm sure air conditioning engine some
electrical engineers may may argue at
that point but
you know it's it's not like uh it's a
bit of a different thing you're making a
totally making a physical product rather
than like an idea yeah because like a
YouTube channel
you can't really grow it in a in a
certain kind in like in like a public
company kind of way because it's like
the reason people go to your channel is
for the specific kind of thing you're
making like you were saying earlier it's
like people are going there because it's
a reliable thing right and the nature of
the growth is to just start diluting the
original creators like intention so we
had some people reach out to us uh and
say hey
um we want to give you guys you know an
investment round to do
whatever you want to do with it an X Y
and Z and I was like okay what if you
were to come in what would you want how
would you how would you make your money
back and he's like and it was all the
same stuff it was like well you're gonna
start new shows you're gonna do shorts
you're gonna do more merchandise You're
Gonna Do products you're going to do and
it's like you know they had a whole plan
but imagine that imagine you know we're
a team of what 15 people yeah and
imagine now it's like okay well now we
need somebody to make the mobile game
now we need somebody to do all the
shorts now we need somebody to do all
the extra merchandise outside of just
the shirts we sell now we need somebody
to do all of that and then all of a
sudden it becomes this unrecognizable
thing when the purpose is to what
well you can make more money it's like I
don't know it's like whose life is made
better in that process you know what I
mean it's like I like making short films
but you know what I'd really like having
to do like a couple hours of approvals
meetings every day
[Music]
no man it's
that's tough stuff and like that's the
thing people don't really warn you about
like and at the end of the day what's it
all for you can't take the money with
you when you go you know it's
experiences that matter so if you're
lucky enough if you're lucky enough to
be in a position where you're building
your own thing and you're making a
profit like sure you could make more
money if you did other decisions but
never forget about like why you're doing
it in the first place and what makes you
happy yeah Reddit
yeah Reddit yeah by the way
if you read the terms of like love
agreement when you upload something to
Reddit it says that anything you upload
Reddit is given a universal in
perpetuity license to use it however
they want no yes it is a blanket
anything you upload is ours forever and
we can do anything we can create we can
we could spin off a series with those
characters mediums now known our
Hereafter devised throughout the
Universe you know I mean there's tons of
problems
it's BS because like clearly something
up was a Disney gift right it doesn't
own the Disney gift but that Reddit says
they do in the agreements and I mean
they went and trademarked Wall Street
bets even though somebody created that
subreddit that was their idea where it's
like oh it's ours now and they try to
see when I was like no
[Laughter]
but you know what there's probably a big
chunk of people I'd be like whatever and
we'll just keep using Reddit
you know well that's probably I mean
there's there'll always be there it is
yeah but I don't think
yeah like new new generations won't move
on there because like I mean kids
growing up now none of them use Facebook
I'm hoping that like my daughter when
she gets into like Elementary School
it's gonna be like uh Instagram that's
lame Tick Tock yeah that's for old
people
I mean for all I know they'll be all
about like neural psychedelics and like
who knows what it'll be at that point
it's gonna be the flashing lights when
they're just like sorry I use direct
nope dopamine neural stimulators oh
thank you very much
um I experience a whole story in the
span of two seconds
um yeah
I don't know but I'm hoping that like
this craze of trying to be an influencer
and like following influencers and like
I'm hoping that my children it's like
it's like yeah we uh we think it's way
cooler just to like go downtown and see
our friends you know yeah they're like
you know I make handmade tortillas
[Laughter]
man I mean it does come down to raising
too you know you can raise your kids
with an interest in those things and
they will Foster an interest in those
things that's true but if but if you I
mean we saw this with JJ uh he started
preschool he's in his classes he has a
friend in his class who him and JJ just
got super into monster trucks hmm like
every day every conversation every their
entire social structure was structured
around monster trucks and we had to we
had to cool it we had to tell him hey
but it's it's fine that you like monster
trucks but there's other things in life
for man you guys are live in this like
metaphor lesson so hard with monster
trucks right now
that's what it was that's gonna be in
the like uh the biopic about JJ when
he's like a retired like monster truck
star driver I mean it's gonna be the
scene where his parents are like there's
more to life than monster trucks JJ
no there's not Mom and Dad
[Laughter]
yeah so we had to cool it on that for a
little while and uh he's come around you
know he's still very much a fan of
monster trucks but it's not the only
thing he does it became the only thing
he was doing and if we hadn't to
recognize that and talk to him about it
and kind of shifted his focus on some of
the things you know and I think that
happens a lot it's just parents they go
oh you know maybe they're not
where they should be or you know as
focused as they should be and kids go
down these rabbit holes and just
whatever it is because they just handed
them an iPad and we're like here here's
the entire world of knowledge yeah yeah
we don't do five enjoy
[Laughter]
our our local library actually has uh
iPad rentals and they have all the like
stuff already set up on it so we'll just
rent one for like two weeks and bring it
back and then get a different one and
it'll have each one has different games
and different you know tools and
different videos and stuff on it but
you're not just you know handing it over
and then just leaving the room I'll see
you in three weeks yeah yeah
yeah yep
come on Reddit come on Reddit
try having some principles be like
YouTube
at least yes
at least it's something a star to shoot
for you know they're not perfect
no company's perfect
yeah
all right well thanks for listening
everybody I hope our rant didn't uh
upset you
and we hope we didn't discourage you
from trying to become a big tick tocker
you know
no it's totally gonna happen you got
this you're different make sure you
leave room for brand Integrations that's
all I'll say
don't be too edgy where a brand won't
give you an integration because then you
probably won't be able to do it as a
living
he wasn't bits of wisdom we'll have to
have like a business podcast at some
point here
I think he's just dead man yeah I guess
[Laughter]
all right all right everybody
see you later
take it easy